à mérignac près de bordeaux c'est la
consternation chez inès da aux mères de
trois enfants il a été sauvagement
assassiné en pleine rue guy-mollet par
son ex compagnon malgré l'interdiction
d'entrer en contact avec elle cet homme
violent continuer ses allées et venues
et vivait à quelques centaines de mètres
de sa victime
très ému le voisinage vient se
recueillir au domicile de chatenay zh
c'est une petite martyrs qui est parti
et elle est partie dans des souffrances
atroces
on dit toujours ne faut pas que ça se
reproduise mais ça se reproduit dort
même les voisins écoeuré ne veulent plus
témoigner à l'image mais dresse le
portrait d'une femme qui a tout fait
pour s'en sortir
en algérie elle avait rencontré cet
homme avec lequel elle s'était mariée
qui l'avait ramené en france il ya cinq
ans elle avait déjà deux enfants d'une
précédente union
puis un troisième est née chez inès
vivait dans ce quartier pavillonaire
charmant de mérignac avec son bourreau
déjà cette fois condamnés qui ne cessait
de la frappe et ses amis parlent de
coquard
les voisins décrivent décrit l'un d'eux
est venu l'a relevé sur le trottoir un
jour alors qu'elle venait d'être battu
mais shahinaz a fini par porter plainte
en juin 2020 l'homme a été condamné à 18
mois de prison dont neuf avec sursis
la jeune femme recommence alors à vivre
travail compte passer son permis de
conduire faite dîner chez son voisin
elle explique qu'elle ne veut pas être
selon ses termes une cassos et qu'elle
veut tout faire pour ses enfants sa
sortie de prison au bout de cinq mois
seulement en décembre malgré
l'interdiction de s'approcher de la
victime
l'ex-compagnon revient vivre au domicile
et les violences reprennent chahinez lui
demande de partir dès lors ils rendent à
proximité et menace la jeune femme elle
se barricade chez elle où va dormir chez
ses amis puis le bourreau la tire dans
un piège et tente de l'étrangler sur un
parking en mars dernier mais les
autorités n'agissent pas jusqu'au jour
funeste du 5 mai où il revient pour lui
tirer dessus
l'aspergé d'un liquide inflammable et
l'immoler mais comment se fait mini site
at il été possible encore une fois
malgré les nombreux précédents chahinez
avait tout fait pour se protéger de
suite à l'agression qu'ils avaient eu
devant un supermarché local par rapport
à là où elle habitait donc voilà donc il
y avait une
dépôt de plainte mois de mars une vigie
siamois 2 avril 2021
c'est là j'ai reçu et elle souhaitait
que soient vraiment appliquées les
décisions avec cette addiction de
contacts et de paraître que c'est pas la
même chose autour de chez elle même si
elle avait un enfant comme tous les deux
donc elle voulait savoir si ce continuer
à se présenter parce qu'il y aurait
passé autour de chez elle
si comme moi vous pouvez faire pour
faire déclarer le non respect de ces
règles là il est bien suivi qui est
organisée parce qu'il était et s'était
fait partie des dossiers du spip de la
gironde où d'après les informations
qu'on a il allait au rendez vous donc il
n'ya pas de souci il se présentait après
voilà le les interdictions est-ce que ça
a dû être rappelé mais il n'a pas de
vouloir les entendre les premières
conclusions de la mission d'inspection
souligne une suite de défaillance qui
peuvent être reprochées à différents
acteurs dans la communication et la
coordination entre les services
la mission va se poursuivre pour
caractériser ces dysfonctionnements et
proposez les initiatives propres à y
remédier les conclusions paraîtront dans
quelques semaines d'ici là le ministre
de la justice eric dupond moretti a
déclaré qu'il allait inciter les
magistrats à utiliser davantage le
bracelet anti rapprochement les
téléphones grave danger les ordonnances
de protection
trois mesures opérationnelles qui de son
point de vue ne sont pas suffisamment
utilisé la france dispose de 1000
bracelet anti rapprochement qui bipent
silex violent approche dans le périmètre
de sa victime
mise en place depuis quatre mois seuls
76 ont été installés et l'homme violent
doit être d'accord pour le porter d'une
part les juridictions disent ne pas en
disposer de temps d'autre part à l'aune
du nombre des ex-conjoints dangereux ce
millier paraît dérisoire pour le cas de
shine est son ex compagnon avaient
interdiction de l'approcher me le
faisait continuellement il avait donné
une adresse de complaisance sans que
cela ne déclenche une réponse des
autorités lorsque chahinez a porté
plainte après son étranglement en mars
un avis de recherche a été émis mais
personne ne semble avoir été interrogé
pour savoir où il se trouvait réellement
il a continué d'aller et venir au vu et
au su des voisins ni le téléphone grave
danger mais le bracelet anti
rapprochement nous ont été données à
shine aise
le 6 février le ministre de l'intérieur
gerald
darmanin a rappelé que les forces de
l'ordre devaient systématiser les
saisies d'armes en matière de violences
intrafamiliales et ce dès la plainte
or le tueur on avait en sa possession
après tout les annonces de façade
son assassinat barbare va-t-il enfin
déclencher des mesures drastiques de
fermeté pour faire baisser le nombre de
féminicide